the national library of medicine
intramural research program a woman with
short blonde hair wearing glasses sits
in front of an all-white background
patricia flatley brennan rn phd facmi
director national library of medicine
nlm has a 50-year history of conducting
research here on the nih campus we call
this our intramural research program
scientists working in various capacities
the research that we do
uses mathematics and computer science
techniques to understand truth and
clinical experiences by looking at large
data sets valerie florence phd acting
scientific director intramural research
program i believe that research is the
heart of the library and should be there
exterior of the nlm entrance and we are
the world's library and we have research
researchers working with data it's
important because it will advance the
approaches used in libraries all over
the world to manage and integrate and
find data so we can all get healthier
faster samir antani ph.d tenure track
investigator computational health
research branch there's always more
research to be done i think we are the
cusp at the beginning of trying to
understand
human bodies and the information that is
contained in it building one entrance on
the nih campus each day different parts
of the nih are discovering new things i
think that presents nlm with an
opportunity to keep toe to toe so that
the two can work together dr antoni
seeded at his workstation looking at
x-ray images now our intramural research
program actually has two key components
white text over a blue background
computational biology in our
computational biology branch
investigators use bioinformatics tools
to understand the structure and function
of genes and other kinds of protein data
white text over a blue background
computational health in our
computational health informatics branch
our investigators are trying to draw
insights out of information about the
clinical process of patients close-up of
the pubmed.gov search page or the
literature that describes clinical care
what's exciting is that we've actually
unified these two programs under a
single umbrella white text over a blue
background intramural research program
computational biology plus health
research a really special thing
is
training and mentoring a next generation
of scientists lauren porter ph.d stedman
tenure track investigator intramural
research program nlm has a really strong
track record in computation there are a
lot of excellent scientists here and so
i thought it would be great to be able
to work with them various shots of lord
porter working in a lab and i'm really
happy to be here and be able to like
take chances that i probably couldn't do
in most other environments
we have an opportunity before us
where
a woman looks at a computer screen
comparing genetic data while another
woman looks at a medlineplus.gov website
all our findings once translated would
reduce the barriers to access to
medicine improve treatability improve
early detection which leads to better
quality of life our whole goal is to
understand more about how living things
work in order to improve the health of
humans
the grain blue nlm logo over a white
background with blue text serving
scientists and society
you